we have seen the destruction
that Russia has wrought on the Ukrainian
people we see the missiles every day
bombing buildings and bumming their
infrastructure and they have to be held
accountable for that and the registry is
one step toward laying that Foundation
of accountability so that in the future
we have the mechanism we have the legal
basis for holding Russia accountable we
know that Ukraine is fighting a war for
all of us that this is about saving the
world as we say in in the U.N Charter
from the scourge of war and so we have
to stand with Ukraine as long as it
takes and President Biden has been very
clear that we will stand with Ukraine as
long as it takes and I heard that
message delivered by all of the leaders
from Europe